foreign
weekly hangout every Tuesday at 2PM
Pacific right here on gamespot.com how
are you doing happy July 5th to you all
happy 5th of July Mike that's how it
works right into you and to you Aaron
happy fifth of July we broke away from
England who just broke away from Europe
I know might as well be on a different
planet Earth I was thinking of Jupiter
that's why Jupiter we put a Juno was the
Juno thank you Eric Richard Lee behind
the camera had given us all his
astronomy astrology tips did you see
that NASA launching probes and [__] yeah
like the video I watched someone like
actually edited a video of it with music
it was even cooler is NASA lit a
dumpster fire in space couple weeks ago
did they really yeah they literally just
put a bunch of trash in a spaceship and
set it on fire and they got drunk and
peed on the side of the Space Shuttle
it's great these are all things that you
can't do in Kerbal Space Program so
hopefully they're going to add that to
it in future future iterations uh how
was your July 4th weekend Michael it was
relaxing yeah barbecue
um drank some pbrs just American stuff
okay it's pretty good yeah yeah I live
with a vegetarian and I'm currently not
drinking yeah so neither of those no I
ate some chips I had some green beans
and broccoli at some point broccoli is
that a very American no but it's green
it's a vegetable oh okay so vegetarians
would probably like broccoli vegetables
broccoli I I ate some broccoli would
have a vegetarian only two days ago well
there's delicious evidence there you go
Aaron Thompson how was your wonderful
July 4th good take the kids to the
carnival it was fun cool which carnival
rides are free up in Marin County oh
sweet but they got us on the lemonade I
bought like 24 worth of lemonade that's
where they get you geez Louise uh do you
see any fireworks
because like the California thing is
like they're not really legal right
what's the state law here the state laws
they super catch things on fire in the
state of California good point I mean
half of the state is usually on fire on
a good day yeah you don't need to add to
the fire that's a fair point uh is
you're you're you grow up in the Bay
area though yeah some counties out uh in
the East like around Sacramento I think
some of those counties you can actually
light fireworks right but don't give a
[__] enemies where most of the fires
already are happening
okay I'm assuming that's the philosophy
um let me know why uh what about you
Mike you grew up on the East Coast was
it yeah do what you want well it was
kind of like a don't ask don't tell in
New York Well we'd have to drive to
Pennsylvania to buy fireworks if you
can't buy them in New York so like all
along the border Pennsylvania New York
there's a bunch of these like gas
stations that aren't really good at all
fireworks and there's no like actually
no there were not fireworks at gas
stations that'd be very irresponsible
strike that there were these like that
didn't happen yeah lots of red barrels
outside the front of the petrol stations
oh yeah we could like you could set them
off New York cops wouldn't really care
that much police officers wouldn't care
that much
um yeah I don't I didn't last so I
startled pretty easily as the office has
figured out okay
and there are these they're like huge
firecrackers going off out near the like
Ocean Beach last night and they didn't
even sound like fireworks there was like
no sparks afterward it was just these
bangs I didn't realize how loud they
were until I went to take like recycling
out yeah and it sounded like someone
threw it at my front door and I
I it scared me a lot last time I go
outside again 3 A.M last night in
Oakland because there were like
fireworks going off all over the place
but at about 3 A.M in like I think like
the car park across the road from our
place there was just this like it was a
bang big enough that I felt the force of
it and I just like like eyes open in bed
and my partner wakes up and she's like
well are we okay I don't know what the
[__] each other make sure he gets shot
right it's like yeah yeah there have
been people literally killed within like
200 feet of our front door yeah
um probably an M80
which is like what a quarter sticker oh
we really think so Dynamite or something
crazy yeah I'm not used to it at all
because we didn't they were like totally
illegal in Ireland because like I grew
up when the troubles were still
happening in the north oh yeah they were
like any explosives like in the Republic
were like nope but the weird thing was
they were actually legal in the north so
people used to drive
cars into Northern Ireland by because
they were part of Great Britain and it
was legal there by fireworks and then
bring them down south okay uh but they
always cost too much I was gonna say
correct me if I'm wrong but knowing my
Irish history the north is yeah where
the problems yes historically man that's
where that's they're legal to buy that
yeah yeah they were there yeah I didn't
I'm sure the reasoning behind the set
not having them was because most of the
bombs that were going off for a long
time were Ira bombs and they were
Republican bombs so I blew out one time
you blew your desk up yeah I was a kid
before I understood physics and I
figured I got a stack of fireworks and I
want to shoot them off in my room so I
gotta so I gotta contain the explosion
Gary's mod in a jar yeah I thought that
made sense
[Laughter]
yeah luckily was plastic that's probably
why I'm still here but it actually blew
up and knocked me on my butt set my desk
on fire and I was like throwing paper
out the window here the door open my
mom's comes my mom comes home
and she walks in right as I'm like
Fanning the flames and get throw him out
the door and she's like huh it smells
like smoke around here and I was like oh
yeah neighbors having a barbecue don't
worry about it oh my God
totally got away with it she never knew
I almost blew my desk up and caught the
house on fire because of the like lack
of knowledge around fireworks uh there
was a similar story in my place where uh
across the road was a psychiatric
hospital across the road from where I
where I grew up and a bunch of us went
in there with like a cherry bomb or
something and we're like are we gonna
build this Cherry but it's gonna be
great and we got the Cherry Bomb and
like we're looking for something like
blow up and the only thing you can find
is this like glass jar like a big glass
jar so we put it in the jar and like lit
the thing like I remember the moments
like I don't even remember much my
childhood but I literally remember this
moment Gary likes the thing drops in the
glass jar and we're all looking at it
and I'm like three of us realize at the
same time [__]
[Music]
blew his hand off
like three years ago oh wow from Game
Spot UK him and his dad make fireworks
and uh he came in one day and he had
like Burns all or down in one hand and
one of them had like detonated and like
burned really badly murder in his hand
yeah they just bypassed most of this in
the state of California by making them
illegal right yeah
in your desks and whatnot yeah geez
Louise anyway that's your fireworks hour
for this year uh tune in next year after
the Fourth of July to hear what limbs we
blew off uh most recently let's talk
about video games Gentlemen let's talk a
bit of video game which a bunch of
people are playing in an alpha right now
um which is great in posting video
content and all that sort of stuff uh
and we've had a I think collectively
over the past couple of months sort of
enough time to play the past couple of
weeks as well
um to sort of get to grips with it uh
Aaron you're basically like yourself and
Ryan are basically like the battlefield
experts here in the office and Mikey
plays a bunch as well you are like World
War One expert as well
um I love Battlefield series I used to
play in a Vietnam Clan I haven't been
too into it since Battlefield 3 or so
but I thought it'd be cool to get the
three of us here together and just sort
of like talk shop like say okay what do
we think about Bill one we've played
like a long put like hours into it at
this stage
um some of us more than others uh and
and what do we feel about it Aaron first
of all what what's your take on
Battlefield one my first impression when
I fired at Battlefield one we played it
at E3
um it was the closed alpha build so
there's a lot that can still change
between now and when they're done was
they've they listened to Fan feedback
and they got it this time like I think
they understand
like how to make classes different they
understand how to make objectives more
fun they understand like finally that
people when they said destruction they
meant building destruction and ground
deformation
just everything at this stage feels so
competent and awesome
um the setting itself it's a little
funny it's definitely I think it's Rob
Handler pointed out in a piece it's
definitely fantasy world war one like
it's World War II in World War one which
is probably was necessary to appeal to
the core Battlefield fans because they
couldn't slap Scopes and automatic
rifles right in authentic World War one
and I think that just wouldn't have
worked for this audience yeah but it it
feels very familiar some of the things
are will feel like reskins to you but
like not in a bad way at all so like I'm
interested to hear you set up because
you're somebody who has been very
critical of dice with Battlefield 3 on
Battlefield 4 and sort of in in
different ways what were the core things
you think they needed to change with
Battlefield 1 like what were the things
coming out of Battlefield 4 that you
were like particularly grieved about I
actually really did like three I thought
it was a good compromise although that
was the moment when they started caring
more about Graphics than destruction and
then that carried through to four where
I just felt four was very conceptually
weak it just had no identity yeah they
kind of threw 3.5 or something felt like
it did feel like 3.5 and also just
nothing felt very unique in that game
and one of my biggest problems was that
I feel like they put all this thought
into Levolution yes but what they put
their thought into was the spectacle of
Levolution and not the way that
Levolution plays and a lot of the maps
including siege of Shanghai got real
boring after the Levolution happened or
the Levolution was crazy underwhelming
yeah
um so I think again like that was
another case where they just didn't
understand that people told them they
wanted destruction but they didn't
understand that they weren't just
talking about the spectacle of
Destruction they were talking about
meaningful destruction and there's a lot
of that in this uh I was really
surprised Mike I remember you came on a
couple weeks ago and talked about your
experience you know hiding in a you know
bunker shell basically
um uh you know while everything else is
going on around you and using that like
little hole to to gain back your health
or whatever
um I've played a couple of matches
recently and couldn't believe how vastly
it's like it's what they were promising
forever that like the levels do actually
change by the end of it it's just like
it was a Zeppelin's crush this town
there's like potholes where there
weren't potholes before it looks almost
indistinguishable and what's your take
on the sort of the evolution the
revolution as it were in the game and
like how that actually manifests like in
terms of gameplay yeah to speak to what
Aaron was just saying it's not just like
it's not just an aesthetic thing anymore
it's an actual like there's
functionality to it right yeah I told
that story about like there's five of us
holding out in this Outpost you could
hear our artillery coming in the sound
design this game even like in the alpha
is unreal it's very it's integral to how
you play and like what you know you're
doing and what you think you should do
next and whatnot but you hear the
Whistle the artillery come in all other
four other people get killed I'm half
dead but the artillery self created a
crater that I crawled into didn't even
have to fire my gun I just waited there
to hold down the Outpost until more
people can get there in like armored
trucks
um and then there's footage of me from
when I'm sniping I'm the Scout uh Rob
and I were playing a match back at E3
and um went into the this like attic of
this or like the loft of a barn there's
a small window with like a little
windowsill over it it's like oh [__] I
can't see anything all of a sudden half
the place gets torn Away by the enemy
team because he knew I was in there so
he was just like pummeling it so I went
prone killed a few people uh the window
itself got torn out so I like had like a
sight line all of a sudden that wasn't
there five seconds ago yeah it's a it's
a game of those types of stories like
we're all exchanging those stories which
like reminds me of kind of a bit like
Bad Company where you'd have you know
people have been talking about it they
should go back to back company for years
and this feels really close too we were
kind of talking about it earlier and I
had a situation earlier which felt like
it was taken right at a Saving Private
Ryan where it was like oh I'm in a clock
tower sniping people I've had like real
trouble on the ground artillery sort of
like learning the pace of Battlefield
again but up in this clock or up in this
like windmill I guess it was
um I was feeling really confident there
was a bit of the wall broken off and it
was a good spot it was facing two
control points I killed like seven dudes
in a row which are like with the like
leading scope where you're like shooting
where they're going to be which is so
satisfying they also added in bullet
drag this time oh right yeah really
fascinating so the bullets actually slow
down over distance wow that's I didn't
realize that actually so it'll make
it'll make it so people who are snipers
or scouts or even uh support will have
to be a little bit more skilled yeah and
probably can't murder you from halfway
across the map necessarily
um and yeah I was killing all these guys
and then you know as what happens in
your sniper eventually they turn on you
and start knowing where you are and
firing and they were firing on me and
suppressing me but I was still like not
getting killed and then I heard that
whistle yeah and then the whole thing
just blew up and it was like you know
what that was all right I don't mind
getting killed that way uh how do you
feel the vehicles are turning out this
time around iron the vehicles will feel
very familiar to Battlefield 3 and 4
fans
um you have a car which is essentially
the same as the mrap right um which was
just the light the light fast vehicle
you have I think a heavy tank which is
very similar to the Amtrak from three so
you'll feel right at home if you play
Battlefield and I I'm assuming one of
the things they wanted to accomplish
with this world war setting was not to
alienate Battlefield fans and they
wanted things to still feel familiar to
them
um
so the vehicles feel good they feel
familiar there's nothing like we didn't
we haven't seen the horse yet right yeah
which is the one thing where I I don't
think they could I mean unless they make
it exactly like the motorcycle right
yeah you're not wondering about the
horse though it's kind of funny
I haven't I've noticed on this one yet
but usually when you walk away from
vehicles in Battlefield like 30 feet
they explode so like are you just like
what do you do with a horse do they
explode in a bunch of guts or you're
like oh you've seen enough Bessie like
go off into the pasture I mean if you
played enough Red Dead Redemption you
just shoot them in the head right watch
them flop down
um there's something about this which
feels very reminiscent of playing 1942
where there are these massive battles
and in a way I'd maybe it's because I've
been playing a lot of OverWatch recently
and you feel like you're so engaged in
like the the victory but there's so much
about this game when you do feel like
you're a small Cog in a big Battlefield
um is that okay do you think Mike
because obviously like feeling like
you're engaged in like your importance
to success is clearly important of
itself yeah I mean there's more than
there's so many ways to be integral to
your team uh just today they're just you
know like I was watching someone on
YouTube or whatever but uh they're like
sorry let E3 we were I was playing and I
was a scout and I spent like maybe three
total minutes running around the edge of
the map to get to the monastery it's
like the the map that the closed Alpha
had yeah the San Quentin Scar and I
spent about three minutes just running
around the edge didn't see anybody
didn't even nobody saw me from what I
know but then I got to the monastery
locked it down I didn't fire a single
shot for like five total minutes but it
still was a capture point which is a
huge deal right yeah I mean like it's so
impressive how this the scale of these
battles changes despite the fact that
there are massive I'll be I prefer
playing as a scout if I haven't like
hinted at that yet um so I'll be trying
to hit someone from across the map I'll
be waiting for them to stand still from
like how many 100 yards away so I can
get the shot but then I'll go into a
farmhouse with my pistol out some guy
with a hatchet will just smoke me uh the
actual scale like switching from Close
Quarters to long range to this tank was
coming at me and I ran behind a wall and
I still wasn't used to destructive
environments yeah I was like all right
I'm safe I'm just gonna try to play cat
Mouse on this wall no he just blew it up
and I was staring him in the face uh
it's just the different encounters that
you come across and like you said the
stories you come out from these matches
with it's it's you know it's close Alpha
but it's enticing it's kind of
encouraging I like the fact that it's
not the sterile thing you jump into
every time you know like Call of Duty
and I haven't played infinite Warfare
yet obviously but you jump into these
matches and it's the same thing over and
over it's just twitch gameplay you're
trying to get like you're trying to get
this many kills trying to you know be
number one in the ranks but then this
there are so many different ways to get
points for your team and kind of Aid the
effort like whether it's just
contributing fire to an Airship or
guiding a tank into the right Outpost at
the right time to just lock it down for
there's 10 seconds more or stuff like
that it's it's so cool to see how these
battles can unfold with you like in
different roles yeah and that's the way
it kind of feels different to me is that
we look at a lot of the footage of this
game and I certainly felt this way until
I got Hands-On with it was that oh like
I get it it looks like a kind of a
reskin the battles are slightly bigger
but there is a totally different pace to
this like I feel like my time to death
is like way longer like I'm I'm existing
in the world a lot more a lot of this in
a way that reminds me of like
Battlefield 2 a lot as well yeah on that
point I think a lot of this is a return
to what was good about previous
battlefields uh feel like they went
through the the line and just picked out
the good bits of everything and then put
it into this game so time to kill is
longer which is refreshing given more
modern games they went back to at least
in the alpha class based so you don't
have the carbines of four that make
everybody do everything you really do
have to stick within your class and roll
and if a tank rolls up on you as a medic
yeah there's not a whole lot you can do
about it yeah you got to choose better
and move better
um the Zeppelin's interesting actually
the Zeppelin's the first time in this
game where and it's it is similar to the
AC-130 but as opposed to being tied to a
base it's tied to the losing team yeah
and it's the first time I think that
they've done something to try and help
match his balance better
it's interesting though because it's a
it's a decision you have to make if you
get into the Zeppelin you can destroy
most of the map but you can't capture
capture points yes so you'll still lose
from on high it's it's a it's a balance
it's there to help you but it won't win
the match for you I liked how when it
happens uh as the sort of attacking team
it was almost It's gotta I have to stop
with all the OverWatch references but it
reminds me of when like Tracer runs into
the back of your team where suddenly you
have this thing you have to worry about
you didn't have to worry about before
like there's this massive holicking
thing that's like making its way across
the map and it's even if you're not like
attacking it all the time you're like
getting to it like you're like oh I'm
right beside like a sh you know whatever
like a big gun like a standing gun I
should go and start taking a couple of
shots it's like on your mind the whole
time like a menace yeah like a menace
exactly there was times where I was
running along and I was looking at it
and I'm like don't hit me don't hit me
don't hit me and you can see it kind of
going boom like hitting near you and I
was like like and then it like made me
change the direction I was going in to
try and get to the objective so yeah
it's like it's a really interesting
thing like intimidating sort of factor
there I'm like it's one of those moments
where I think it was like maybe it
wasn't Caspian border what was the one
with the with the large telephone pole
in the middle of it was that that was
kind of thing yeah yeah so I remember
like seeing that fall down for the first
time was like Wow and like just sitting
back and going that's awesome mama
that's definitely blew up it was like it
was like hell it was like raining down
and I saw like cars driving away trying
to get away from it and it's just awful
like it's just this flaming like mass
and then the fact that like later then
in that map I was trying to like get one
of the objectives with with a little
Battalion and or a squad and like we
were just like literally jumping over
parts of the thing that had like torn
this Village apart it's just I yeah it's
interesting in so many ways that I
wasn't really expecting yeah Rob Handler
he had mentioned the idea that if you're
driving the Zeppelin you know it's about
to go down try to position it in a way
that you know you're losing the Airship
you might as well try to make it more
difficult for the other team to like get
to a crucial checkpoint if possible you
know like position it so it's gonna be
this choke point it'd be this like
almost new trench like a new trench
almost yeah and that's the thing um most
Shooters nowadays are very reactionary
right um there's more forethought in
this now just base just based on the
closed Alpha that feels like placement
is so much more important it's not
necessarily lining up the right shot
it's like I don't know I'm reminded of
like the Wayne Gretzky quote he says
like good players go where the puck is
great players go where the Puck's gonna
be yeah so I feel like Battlefield like
it's returning to those roots like Aaron
said where it's more about like thinking
through a few moves and like where you
can be not necessarily to get like two
or three kills but where you can be to
kind of actually impact the flow of the
battle in the next five minutes and
that's like a really refreshing thing in
the modern shooter landscape uh it's
gonna be super interesting to see what
they do with the single player aspect of
this uh last thought on this Aaron what
do you think what else do you want to
see from this obviously Alpha closed off
is running at the moment they're
probably going to do more betas and
reveal more multiplayer stuff what what
else would you like them to introduce or
what would you like them to focus on I
think this map in the closed Alpha is
technically extremely competent and
everything mostly like feels great to
play with sounds great
I haven't seen I mean we've only seen
one map I want to see a map that gives
me that sensation we got the first time
we jumped off dama van pee Oh my God yes
like I don't think Battlefield has done
that since damn event Peak right just
something something that just like blows
you away that you've never seen before
yeah I think you always want that from a
game so I I think at this stage they
have technical competence they've taken
the best bits of other battlefields and
put them in place everything's in line
right now
for them to really just blow you away
with something and I don't I haven't
seen that something just yet
but uh you know the Zeppelin's probably
the closest thing to that but I'm
excited to see what what uh what else
they have up their sleeve that'd be cool
yeah some messed up uh some messed up
maps we'll have to see I mean they've
it's been a lot of diversity in the maps
inter and what they've shown the trailer
so I don't know maybe we'll get
something cool there uh both uh thank
you both for coming on and talking about
the battlefields I don't think it will
be the last time we're gonna be talking
about it this year uh so I look forward
to getting you both on in the future
again to talk about it thanks so much
everyone the chat has been chatting away
about it as well a lot of people kind of
having similar things to us a couple
weeks back where they were like not so
sure about it um I think it's gonna be
interesting to see what happens when
more people get their hands on uh Aaron
thank you so much we're gonna cycle you
out Mr Peter Brown is coming on you go
capture more hot maybe Battlefield I
don't know if we're technically playing
it we'll see
what up Peter brand hey gentlemen how
you doing what's up I'm good how are you
guys good how was your fourth of July
it's not bad I'm getting over a cold I'm
still kind of fighting it but I can see
all the fireworks from my apartment
that's cool great view yeah can't
complain fireworks came to you yeah it's
beautiful yeah I saw so far was
completely disconnected from the Fourth
of July I went to an A's game on Friday
uh in the Coliseum and Sony were
sponsoring us which meant that we
basically got like a 30 minute let's
play of MLB the Show after the 10th
inning as it was yeah which is really
weird where they had some like Sony rep
play
they're like four people they had like
semifinals in the finals and in the end
it was so it was a Sony rapper versus
like a [__] 10 year old girl and he
like tried to smoke her like he was just
like completely unrepentant it was like
a what do you call like a home run derby
or whatever yeah and he [__] did his
like best score ever against her and
then she matched it and the whole place
was like booing in as he was doing this
and then at the end they were like oh
it's a drawer we'll spit the prizes and
she got like a PS4 which is pretty cool
and he got like a signed like Jersey
yeah [__] captive I was like give it
to the girl what's wrong with you yeah
and then it was fireworks he's like it
was a large male wouldn't fit her yeah
there you go yeah patriarchy exists in
freebies uh yeah so I got it it was
pretty cool but I I turned up to the I
didn't realize where my my better half
like surprised me with the tickets yeah
so I was right
so unfortunately both halves of me were
wearing shorts and a t-shirt in the
[__] Coliseum so I was freezing for
like six Innings yeah and then we had to
wait an hour for the fireworks to start
and then it took it it was it was rough
man anyway damn we talked a lot about
fireworks today
do you have any cool firework uh stories
no anecdotes nope never blew off a lamb
or no or threw it at something you
didn't like you're all doing good no I'm
set in your Ivory Tower and watched them
for his whole life it's kind of I've
described it to Mike as this King in the
castle syndrome where I can like see San
Francisco like pretty much all of it
from my apartment so I'm like I can I
can tell what's happening I don't need
to go anywhere I'm good here just keep
an eye on things I'll just sit here and
pay play fury yeah let's talk about Fury
let's do it uh Fury is a game that I
knew nothing about until I came in this
morning and I was like hey Pete what you
playing there uh so it's free on
Playstation network this week for for
PSN uh PS plus yeah free for PlayStation
Plus users I think 25 otherwise okay
um that's a that's a real good deal for
PlayStation Plus then I guess yeah I
think this is one of those games that's
priced maybe higher than most people are
willing to accept for what it is right I
mean I think you know we can talk about
value all day but anyway the game is
free so if your PlayStation Plus user I
definitely recommend you buying it
um it's not on PC as well it's out on PC
as well
um this game is shown off at E3 two
years ago as part of Sony's press
conference and it's a
sort of it's like a neon like stylish
like cel-shaded
twin stick shooter slash bull hell slash
swordplay game yeah talk about the
structure because I needed to like watch
you play to sort of understand how
exactly yeah it's like it's like
somewhere between a fighting game and
like a boss fight game it's all boss
fights there are sort of narrative
sections that tie uh your whole journey
together uh but essentially you are in a
circular Arena against a boss you are a
guy that has a laser gun and a sword you
can Dash you can Parry attacks stuff
like that
um but these boss fights it's not just
like the boss has one health bar the
whole thing is defeating a boss in
different stages so one boss may have
five or six stages but within those
stages of a battle there are too many
stages one which is sort of the the long
range thing that's more like a twin
stick shooter where you're dodging
bullets and you know trying to uh Parry
attacks that you know the enemy is doing
up close when you Whittle their health
down enough then it goes into this close
range Sword Play thing and the camera
Zooms in and it's really close and it's
all about parrying and dodging these
unblockable attacks in time
and the game the game is all about
punishment both in uh taking advantage
of your enemy when they slip up uh
avoiding punishment when you slip up
because when you do the computer really
just kicks your ass
um
and uh yeah like you you have to put in
like 20 minutes sometimes to beat these
battles and they're super hard they're
super hard yeah like you know you have
to be diligent at all times and if you
screw up
it only takes a few hits for a boss to
basically put you on the brink of death
meanwhile you're spending like 15
minutes getting them close to where to
where you're almost finished and it's
it's an aggravating game but it's also
it's very fair like it's it's difficult
on purpose and you have to be a glutton
for punishment kind of to appreciate it
or just really freaking good so how many
I guess like how long is it how many
like because you haven't beaten it yet
how many bosses have you like come up
against five I think there are eight
total there's like one scene where they
show sort of like a series of planets
descending
um and I think I kind of ate I've gotten
through five at this point
um and is it like is it like a single
run where you need to like kill them all
in a row without dying or like no saving
in between each fight yeah you save in
between each fight
um
yeah but but man like I've spent hours
on a single fight before and uh and it
was always the sort of thing where I'd
get like 80 of where I needed to be but
then like something would happen in that
last 20 either I wasn't I didn't know
what to do or I slipped up and like let
frustration get the better of me and
then I had to just start over and it's
one of those things where you're like do
I want to sit here for another 20
minutes and like beat my head against
the wall you kind of do like it's a
really fast game that feels really great
when you succeed so are you playing up
because you feel like you have to
because you want to review it or are you
actually like going back because you're
enjoying it uh it's um Elizabeth I mean
I'm reviewing the game so I have to beat
it but
um I I'm enjoying playing it like it's
there's something about it's one of
those things where you know you put it
down after being frustrated for a while
and you come back the next day and then
you're like oh man like this is what I
was missing yesterday like I'm feeling
pretty good now and that that feeling is
great it's gratifying and it makes you
appreciate the game a little bit more so
I'm finding that the more I I play it
the more I love it cool yeah good stuff
Mike you interested in playing this bad
boy all Fury yeah I mean I hate the
comparison because it's kind of overused
lately like to ill effect a lot but Dark
Souls yeah
I have to say because I've been wanting
to replay again but I mean it seems like
something despite the fact that you
might be putting like you said 20 to 30
minutes into these boss fights from what
I saw the moment-to-moment gameplay
seemed satisfying and fun enough that I
would want to replay those bosses just
to beat them yeah yeah like I just
started replaying the earlier bosses
today to show you the game actually and
and it was fun like I having that
knowledge like gives you a different
perspective
um so it's yeah it's certainly like
something punishing like Dark Souls like
you have to be on point you have to know
what you're doing I just have to say
that the chat groups you said about a
minute ago waiting for someone to say
dark souls-esque yeah it says Bingo
thanks Mike yeah I'll throw it in there
did you play Battlefield yeah that's
pretty Dark Souls best but I mean like
for aesthetically it seems appealing to
me the fury I mean yeah it looks cool it
reminds me of El Shaddai Ascension it
probably reminds me that because you had
told me like last week um but and that
was like the one thing I liked about El
Shaddai I didn't really like the combat
but I liked how weird and kind of
stylized it was so good that alone is
like the surface appeal is enough to
maybe drop me in at the very least yeah
if we're gonna make comparisons it's
like El Shaddai hyper light Drifter and
then yeah maybe something like dark
souls in terms of the underlying good
soundtrack difficulty soundtrack is
amazing uh I had Mike sort of started
introducing me to this band uh Carpenter
brute just last week
um and then I was looking into Fury and
I was watching a trailer and I was like
this soundtrack's pretty good so I
looked up the trailer and I was like
[__] Carpenter brute is on the
soundtrack uh it's it's great it's this
uh this genre called outrun which I was
not really that familiar with before but
it's it's sort of like the the the
neo-noir like techno stuff of the 80s
where you had like a a dark like Sullen
like lone person who's trying to like
persevere against horrible odds it
sounds like like perturbator style yeah
exactly they're on the soundtrack okay
it's like hardcore upscale like uh like
Up Tempo Kavinsky if you see like Drive
imagine drive on like Coke I don't know
but or did you know it yeah I don't know
what are you talking about or like uh
have you seen like hobo with a shotgun
it's that kind of yeah you should watch
that oh man I spent a lot of the weekend
playing uh The Witcher 3 blood and wine
which starts off with three goddamn boss
fights in a row oh yeah do something
about this game which is like that was
traumatic enough as it is the boss
fights are really special right like
it's one of video game's greatest
Traditions yeah but usually that sort of
game like this is relegated to like you
know you unlock a Boss Rush mode in a
game right or like Mega Man at the end
you'll fight the series of bosses but
it's rare we see a game that is only
boss fights right the shadow of the
classes comes to mind yes punch out as
well
um or I feel like we're having the same
conversation we did this morning but
whatever but like every fighting game is
almost like a boss Rush game totally but
yeah there's like this this real sense
of like you know it's it's a really
potent experience and and how you take
it is uh it kind of defines whether you
like it or not so I know you haven't
completed yet but how about that uh how
about that Doom boss fight at the end
yeah it's pretty good yeah boss fights
good stuff yeah let's not talk about
that I haven't gotten there yet yeah
complete Doom complete them and then
complete inside
next to me last week all right yeah I
don't don't don't look up don't look it
up just play the game it's real good
anyway all right that's enough when's
the review going up for free hopefully
tomorrow I've been sick like just in a
puddle of my own filth so I'm just great
sick I'm trying to pull myself out of
that um six out of ten yeah I'm gonna
try my oh shoot we're going to see a
movie tonight yeah what movie you're
gonna see uh Swiss Army okay Paul Daniel
and Daniel Radcliffe and for those who
want to know it's f-u-r-i not f-u-r-y if
you're looking for anything about this
game yeah and it's free like seriously
play if you have a PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation Plus just play the game yeah
that's all I can say yeah and who
doesn't have PlayStation Plus when
they're on PlayStation 4 right now some
people people don't play online I guess
yeah yeah all right there you go okay
gentlemen hi it's halfway through the
year
yours hop over
the sand keeps falling
we're all getting older
let's talk about video games
um game of the year will be happening
six months from now or maybe five I
don't know I forget how that works
started December right yeah yeah we got
a bunch of games coming out between now
and then we'll talk about that later but
I thought it'd be fun and entertaining
since we have the reviews editor
gamespot.com here and also this guy Mike
who reviews games
uh to talk about some of the games that
came out earlier and sort of gauge where
we are with you know the game of the
year contenders yeah uh and whatnotch so
I just look at the list you shared you
did what did you think of the list
yes perhaps intentionally oh yeah okay
so let's get right down to it uh first
of all the game we gave 10 out of 10.
Uncharted 4. yeah the fourth Uncharted
game uh who reviewed this bad boy
oh that was me oh it was you Michael
yeah all right one of the best games in
2016. yeah so far I like it a lot I
don't I don't know uh
think about the main thing I love about
it is how everything about it coalesces
to create this like really
cohesive amazing experience between the
writing and the dialogue and the
characters uh the gameplay itself I
think was great but I think what makes
it so good is that it goes back and
corrects a lot of the mistakes that the
trilogy made that made it kind of such a
renowned series I guess and problems I
had with the series going through it I
think four actually not only addressed
problems it had gameplay-wise
mechanically and uh thematically but it
also looked like Nathan Drake himself
and it was actually one of the more
interesting uh like
I don't know this sounds way too
academic but like like character studies
but it's also it was also just the
spectacle of everything like that chase
scene and Madagascar through the
marketplace yeah through the mud uh the
beginning the opening boat sequence and
some people had mixed feelings about I
think that actually worked well as the
ending the ending was tremendous final
two hours oh yeah it's uh it also just
it kind of sets up the first three games
in a way if you like haven't played in
the games I would yeah play four and
then go back
um in a weird way it kind of sets it up
as like these legends that they talk
about but uh totally i i as somebody who
barely like I played two and I played
half of three yeah so I wasn't like deep
in it and I sure did a great job of
filling in all those gaps yeah and just
like I mean it's gorgeous which isn't
like usually my main takeaway from games
but it really is uh I think just it
doesn't have any weak aspects to it in
my opinion at all uh the few points
where I actually was kind of felt like
it was dragging it was actually still
kind of integral like these characters
would have these incidental
conversations that became pretty
uh integral later on yeah which I didn't
expect and uh how the relationships play
out I think is actually really
satisfying as a fan of the series I
think they tied it off really well I
could not have asked for a better finale
um but also you know just like I think
naughty dog did a lot of things better
here than they did with the last of us
which previously I thought was their
best game yeah totally for one of the
best action games I've ever could like
just in terms of the combat never
controlled and you know move movement
within the Arenas and stuff was so much
fun uh Peter let's talk about another
game which has great movement and great
shooting uh which you reviewed uh much
more recently Doom yeah what a pleasant
surprise that one was dude I did not see
Doom coming you're not standing at early
review copies man must be a piece of
trash that was that was one discussion
no that was not Pete while all that was
going on he was playing it at his desk
and I went over and was like I was doom
and you were like it's pretty good yeah
his eyes are bleeding it's good dude
like they had the E3 demo they showed
off when the game was announced like did
not leave me interested at all in the
game at all I thought I I will not care
about this Doom is over as far as I'm
concerned and now I feel like Doom has a
better future than it probably ever had
um the game is just it's it's such a
pure experience that just
gets your heart racing and uh you know
and it's and it's spectacular to look at
as well some of the environments
although I wish they were more varied
some of the stuff that's in there
especially in hell is just like really
wonderful set pieces yeah
um
a definite surprise yeah I never thought
that we'd be talking about Doom in July
and saying like it's like a genuine game
of your Contender it's absolutely one of
the best for it was one of these things
where like 10 minutes in I was like all
right that was a you guys know what
you're doing already because that intro
chapter was like very self-aware about
like the waste that comes with doom yeah
and the sort of the fact that they were
like so self-aware and so like light on
the like playing up the sort of lore
aspect of the game and then also being
like we're not gonna don't worry it's
not Doom three We're Not Gonna spend 30
minutes setting this up before you shoot
somebody you know he pushes the screen
away and as the more I played the more I
was like I was so reticent to believe
that this was good I was like this can't
be good right it's like nothing about or
like is my previous off like yeah
totally is my interpretation of this
just like weird like is this nostalgia
rotation solo that now a game that's
actually like mediocre I'm enjoying
right but it's [__] great like it's
so like up until the final boss fight
and I get I'm so burnt out of first
procedures up until the final boss fight
like and that then that was amazing and
I literally was like I'm gonna play you
again in a couple of weeks like yeah and
I'm super stoked to see that they've
added the whole uh the weapon
positioning in the shot where it just
sticks the gun right in the middle
that's definitely Nostalgia playing a
trick on me but you know I love that I
really want to see what they're doing uh
for DLC I hope there's some coming the
multiplayer stuff I don't really care
about snap map is kind of interesting
but it's even with the sorted list based
on popularity it's hard to really figure
out what the great snap map stuff is the
user created stuff yeah but man if they
can do some cool stuff with DLC like I
will be playing that game again and it's
it's when you think about Game of the
Year right games like Uncharted games or
sorry games like doom and like I guess
OverWatch which we'll probably talk
about soon I assume is uh you know
people have the same positive opinion
there's very few dissenters or outliers
on it comes to how they feel about it
but when you talk about a game like
Uncharted yeah I got a 10 but a lot of
people are like that's a great game but
it's just not that for me yeah so I feel
like Doom is is one of the stronger
contenders let's talk about OverWatch
actually okay let's do it yeah who
reviewed this Mike again all right this
is working out pretty good uh you
enjoyed OverWatch I mean the whole
office enjoys over I should be playing
the [__] yeah no it's I mean for a lot
of the same reasons I mean like not to
linger on Doom too long Doom is like
right up there with rocket league and
like Resogun and that ju they are some
of the it's one of the best feeling
games I've played in like so long uh
OverWatch the same thing you mean the
game is different for everyone almost
like kind of different than Doom it's
everyone who jumps into it yeah it's
pretty universally positive I would say
but you know you jump in as Genji and
it's a different game than if you're
playing at zarya who my favorite
character is if you jump in it's Lucio
you're looking at the game itself and
through a whole different lens you're
looking at it through a different scope
there's different scale to the fights
because you want to keep different
distances based on different characters
it's like this amalgamation of like all
these shooter tropes but you know you
want to say it's like the kitchen sink
approach they went for everything they
did but it all works in this game
somehow it's like they managed to take
like these Universal archetypes from
Shooters across the genre and that from
like and across like the decades pretty
much like they took there's like you
know you got like uh pharah who's very
much like a quake kind of like Arena
style shooter character then you have
McCree who's much more precise and you
have you know Widowmaker is a
counter-strike-ish character and it's
somehow these all coalesce into this one
like
like I said cohesive kind of really good
feeling and very Dynamic experience it's
I don't know it's every time I jump into
a match it's somehow still different and
I've been playing it for how many months
now and I don't see myself slowing down
too much yeah like doom doom is the best
campaign I've played in years OverWatch
is the best online shooter I've played
in donkey's years as well yeah what do
you think about it donkey series I still
can't do you think you should use that
phrase differently every time
I haven't played much OverWatch yet I
really can't talk about it cool yeah
thanks I wish I could
I mean we've talked about OverWatch
enough here on gamespot.com I feel like
it's 21 videos
but I need to play that game though like
there's no question that's fairly
different Gap then uh actually get your
mind out of the gutter one that you
wanna I didn't say it I can I can give
you I'll pass on you if you're gonna
start laughing okay XCOM 2. oh I'll talk
about this for every fifth who reviewed
that overlooked
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you review everything
was kind of overlooked I think so and
you'd like to say maybe it's because
it's not on like consoles but there's a
obviously PC crowd is nothing to I mean
apparently the first one didn't sell
well on consoles right that's why they
went for PC only this time right well I
mean no it's coming to college it is now
which actually gives gives me some hope
that maybe it'll tap into a new crowd
that previously overlooked it yeah but I
mean like they said from the beginning
they're creating the game would not
exist is now if they didn't just focus
completely on PC right
um I mean it feels great it's it's
everything I want from a sequel this is
my main takeaway from it um it took the
depth and the creativity of the first
XCOM and just kind of that blend of the
overarching strategy of like scientific
research and Base building and then
somehow still Taps into that turn-based
tactical combat that you know you think
about when you think of this game
um just between how the different
classes interact the way the odds are
stacked against you the entire time but
yet as soon as I failed a campaign or
got to the point where like this is
hopeless and a lot of times you have to
do that you go back and you start a new
campaign and it's different enough each
time that you're you still feel like
you're making progress even when things
are like just really shitty yeah um I
mean just and then the there's a new DLC
out now or I think it's out I played it
I don't know recently for a preview
Shen's last gift it adds like these
robots which is essentially uh like a
new class so you have like the six
classes now that you can play as and I'm
assuming the console will come with
those classes I'm not positive but
um between like the map design like how
despite the fact that you might know
you're probably gonna lose it's still
fun as hell from yeah like campaign to
campaign yeah super fun game really
enjoyed it I just checked steam to see
if it was in the sales but it's not at
the moment so it's still 60 bucks but uh
worth every penny uh still think uh
let's jump through a couple of these
ones uh Dark Souls three you want to
talk about that I don't know who
reviewed it
I got some
I'm saying the Dark Souls fans are
unreasonably passionate no I used to
count myself among them I still do
um but I you know like I had I was
reviewing the game but and I it still
will probably be my top five at the end
of the year uh I mean even looking ahead
oh steam sales are over actually right
now sorry my bad um did not realize that
uh yeah but still a fine game yeah I
mean my main takeaway maybe not my main
takeaway but in terms of negatives I
feel like they really got tired like
tired toward the end of it like this
this is uh you know Miyazaki wasn't
completely attached to Dark Souls 2 and
a lot of people look at that as the week
entry in the series right um I still
like Dark Souls won the most and then
probably demon souls and then three so
three three is still a great game I
think just in comparison to what I
you've seen from Studio from software do
before
um the bosses in this a lot of times
where you would fight a boss later on
that felt recycled you're like okay uh
the Old King is pretty much just uh
someone I fought earlier on yeah like
and then you'd fight Champion gonder
it's idex gun deer obviously that's the
whole point but it was still like the
momentum with the level design like the
way it's like the the verticality of it
folds in itself and you still like
discovering a shortcut is just as
rewarding as empowering as killing a
boss and no matter how like we were
talking about Fury earlier which is like
a lot of boss fights and a lot of
frustration but at the same time Dark
Souls 3 is very dark souls-esque
no it's uh despite the fact that you're
losing to these bosses time and time
again it's gonna be it's satisfying
moment to moment and like you feel
you're you're so you're rewarded you
know like despite the fact that you
might fighting be fighting recycle
bosses later it's still such an
empowering experience to really feel
like you came out of that game like more
skilled than you went in like by far
certainly a contender I was flicking
through some of the games here checking
our reviews to see if all of them were
reviewed by Mike there are the next two
I looked up were both reviews so I'm
actually going to jump uh to one that I
know you reviewed uh Peter don't worry
about it it's all good March 10th you
guess what I didn't review the game
March 10th
it was Hitman yes it was yes and that
was the first episode I reviewed yes yes
uh what do you think of him have you
played the subsequent episodes I played
up until episode three I've only ever
remembered
the first two episodes
um I'm gonna wait until the full game
comes out and review that yeah because
uh when I played episode three I beat it
in less than an hour right and now
Hitman is a game that you can go back in
and you can mix up the way you can
endlessly replayable Peter right
um but it's in my opinion it's not it's
not good enough to inspire that kind of
um repetition right
um you know specifically the third
episode just to give you an example of
of how cut and dry this game can be like
I was in Marrakesh this bustling City
that's got a huge Market there's a huge
protest going on there's all these
military everywhere and you think oh man
it's gonna be really hard for me to
accomplish my goal so I'm surveying the
area walk down the street some girl is
talking to some guy and there's a little
icon above their head that says hey you
should pay attention to this and I
listen he's like oh yeah my dad's like
got the key to the city or whatever but
he's all retired but he's still upstairs
I guess so I'm like okay so I walk
between them go upstairs the Dad is
sitting by himself so I just murder him
you go downstairs find a military guy
who's sort of out of it and I take his
uh his uniform yeah so then I decide
okay I'm gonna walk into the military
complex walk right through the protest
into the military thing
essentially I overhear another thing
where it's like oh this guy's getting a
massage in about half hour I'm like oh
that's my target okay so I find the
masseuse knock him out take his shirt
find the guy give him a massage choke
him out
he still gave him the massage oh yeah
I'm not unfair you're not an animal just
relaxing before you slit his throat
after the job
um oh you're so tight yeah anyway
there are multiple ways I could have
gone about that many ways that are more
difficult and are and and challenging
yeah but why would I like that's the
whole thing right is that like there are
so many ways of doing this and like then
they have all the different challenges
which like take control away from you or
give you more restrictions and Hitman is
not a game that is inherently fun to
play it is meant to be a mentally
challenging game so when you have these
Solutions handed to you right going back
to do something that isn't fun when
there are lots of other games out there
waiting for your attention it just
doesn't it's not really a thing that is
inspiring to want to do that it's been
interesting I feel like the
chapter-based like release of this has
benefited us because I'm not getting
burned down on it as fast as I think I
would if there was just like a full game
I probably would have played half of
them but like and stopped
um so that's been interesting but yeah
we'll have to see looking forward to the
review uh later this year of the full
project uh let's burn through a couple
of these because we're running a bit
long yeah and Mike Mahari you reviewed
some games Far Cry Primal what you think
of it uh it was surprised me I like how
much it makes use of its setting I think
being like a prehistoric or not
prehistoric kind of like Stone Age
setting they could have easily they had
like oh this machine gun slingshot but
no they stuck to it it was you're like
Spears bow and arrow if you play it on
the new survival mode it's actually
makes like it's really tense the entire
time through when sun falls like the
Predators come out yeah it really it's
one of the better uses of like a setting
it's not realistic at all but it's I
really like when I think of games that
kind of
took these Aesthetics and took these
like these tropes of that time and made
good use of it for fun gameplay I think
Far Cry Primal is like a standout super
surprised by how much have fun it was
and have not a reskin it was like yeah
it's still got all the Ubisoft sort of
tropes but it's pretty good really good
fun uh the witness you also reviewed
that right yeah that one that one that
was one of the more challenging games
I've played I know a lot of people have
didn't have as hard time with it but
well I mean it's a challenging game I
think universally but the way that it
communicates its idea is to you so
subtly it doesn't doesn't hold your hand
at all you just go you're on this island
you go explore you can if you want to go
right to like there's not really a there
is a last puzzle
but you know you need to like activate
these lasers around the island you can
go to one of some of the more difficult
puzzles and if you know how to do it
it's like it's like I don't know if you
spend like three weeks reading a
textbook you're gonna be you're gonna
know something about like basic
chemistry yeah but if you just try to
take a test right at the beginning of
like the semester before you read a book
you're not gonna be able to do it but
this not to be too academic or anything
yeah this sound like such a
I don't know uh yeah the way this game
teaches you its ideas like in such a way
that you actually learn its systems and
how like they interact is so good at
such a the puzzles themselves just seem
like how can you just have these mazes
and move these dots around a maze how
can that be a whole game yeah but then
the people have played like oh my God I
know what the square mean it's like
burning my head that you have to
separate these from those and like this
shape means totally you have to like
fail this on purpose I don't know that
it's really crazy I've still not
completed it I feel like I'm about 75 of
the way through and I'm I'm terrified
now that I've lost the knowledge on it
um but at the same time you could go
back to a puzzle there's a chance you
can go back to a puzzle that was killing
you for days right you'd solve it right
now God I need to jump back gorgeous
looking game uh Peter Brown you review
Street Fighter 5 earlier this year
obviously they promised a lot of fixes
and updates throughout the rest of the
year is there anything about what
they've done so far that makes you feel
like sf5 is in a better place than it
was no I don't think so I think the game
is a really strong core in terms of like
a fighting system I know that there's
some people who have some misgivings
based on what was changed from Street
Fighter 4 but really it's a very sound
fighting game uh the problem with the
model that they've adopted is one that
is you know we're sort of gonna give you
little uh appetizers like along the way
and the full course will be available
you know after a certain amount of time
but it's just
the way that they've handled this game
is a problem but beyond that the game
itself is so easy to walk away from it's
not it doesn't have that infectious
spirit that a lot of past Street Fighter
games have because there's just so
little to it and the modes that they
have put in there outside of just online
competitive matches
are really poorly done so it's a great
game that that just wasn't given the
treatment it deserved uh we got a couple
more games here I want to cut away from
the gameplay we'll put our hands out
we'll do the thing we did at E3 with
like thumbs up thumbs down thumbs middle
and put your hand down if you haven't
played it okay all right all right so
put your hands out first game that comes
through is firewatch
didn't play that down in terms of a game
of the air Contender yeah
um I don't like it as much no no I
thought it was all right okay yeah I
guess uh super hot
yeah yeah I'll give it a good yeah I
feel like um I think I did give it a
good yeah like a literally reviewed it
already uh inside
so played it okay play inside it's
pretty good yeah
Quantum break
[Laughter]
unless you count the two live streams
today I didn't play it no I don't know
yeah not a final Quantum break me and
Peter are sticking to our guns I'm with
you bro I don't know what I don't know I
don't know what the rest of the internet
was smoking that week
um unravel
none of us played it yeah all right okay
fair enough uh and I think that's
everything I've got written down here is
editing you guys were thinking of that I
haven't touched I would like to mention
off-world Trading Company uh it's kind
of it's not what he was going to say no
it's kind of a niche game right it's RTS
but it's there's no like uh military
there's no combat involved it's all
economics it's as if you took like the
economics from a game like Civilization
or I mean like even if you took it from
Starcraft and blew it up and made it
much more complicated in a really fun
way and there's always something to be
doing worrying about how this resource
is going to affect your stock price and
you're trying to buy out the enemy just
sounds like Monopoly sounds like drug
wars it's both of those I guess if you
when Monopoly meets drug wars you get
off-road trading companies so try to
check that out even if you're not an RTS
fan there's a few people in the office
that we played it and I mean I think a
few more pleasantly surprised yeah all
right what do you think of Vader hyper
light Drifter all right again I still
need to play more of but the hours so I
did play was amazing and it's got
amazing reviews as well so I feel like
more people should play that what about
Mighty number nine
don't do that
the game is okay
all right that's all there is to it uh
apparently there was a I read something
over the weekend about the the
kickstarter sort of total for video
games this year is pretty down yeah
board games apparently are super super
up cool yeah they're back yeah Justin
Hayward got some sort of Bejeweled board
game today I don't know who the [__]
thought that was a good idea he just
gave it to me when I was talking to him
he kept like you know like someone's
just holding something to her you're
wondering why they're doing that I don't
want that
uh well those are our picks so far for
game of the year 2016. yeah let us know
what you think should win so far in the
comments below all right gentlemen we're
running a little bit long here but uh
we've already talked about the games
that have come out this year yeah so
let's talk about the games that are yet
to come out this year yeah they're
coming out in the future uh I have this
in some sort of a chronological list I
probably haven't covered everything
apologies in advance internet uh but
let's get right to it first things first
no man's sky at August 9th y'all excited
y'all ready for this dude yeah
excited yeah yeah I'm I'm cautiously
excited because it looks really
ambitious I'm worried if that's gonna be
a detriment like with such a massive
Universe I'm worried that it's
sacrificing substance in the process I
hope they prove me wrong because I'm I'm
really excited to play it I'm curious
yeah I think I've Echo those the uh
those worries I guess what about you
Peter I'm curious but I don't have High
Hopes okay and I don't think that's
worried I think the game is not going to
be as great as everyone thinks really
okay I'm really excited like the thing
that I enjoy from open world games more
than editing is exploring so you don't
need that much
you know I'm my requirement of substance
isn't as high I don't think like I just
enjoy faffing about like I played World
of Warcraft for years and yeah okay
that's a good point
um and just like rambled but uh yeah I
guess we'll see we'll see very soon
August 9th uh Gears of War 4 is that
later that month uh what do you think
Peter I I really like the first Gears of
War and kind of fell off I went back to
play judgment and thought okay but this
is just kind of more Gears of War with
like a little bit of like here's a
moment yeah right [__] that's good
um but I want to see what they can do
right like
it seems to be like the time this will I
think make or break Gears of War if this
doesn't if this doesn't work there's not
gonna be a gears five and I bet you they
know that so like they really have to
put a lot into it so I'm hoping
there is that urgency and it pans out
I'm a huge fan I love the first the
second game of my door third game I
thought was really good as well judgment
was the one that kind of burnt out for
me a little bit sure and I gotta say
like I really want this game to be great
but nothing I've seen in any of the
previews has made me particularly
confident yeah and even playing the
multiplayer beta like I think they did
the really good job of like making a
Gears of War 2 style multiplayer beta
but
guess I just don't want to play Gears of
War 2 multiplayer anymore yeah that's
just it I mean it just it the series
seems to like you can always predict
it's going to be more of what what it
always has been yeah you can do that for
a lot of series but essentially
something like Halo and Gears of War
like yeah I feel like both those series
I'm kind of ambivalent to because it's
like I've kind of been there done that
yeah maybe I'm missing the details but
maybe there's an audience that likes it
somewhere but yeah not for not for us
necessarily what do you think Mike I
played it at E3 I'm actually I think a
little more excited than I was okay it
seems like it's kind of able to get out
of its own way when it needs to because
there's a very like measured campaign
mission I saw not the demo at E3 I
played something different right um at
like this Xbox media showcase and it was
really it took its time in developing it
like an atmosphere and tone it felt like
more like there was horror overtones now
right and I like I actually like the
characters
um
the JD Phoenix JP I don't remember his
first name it's Marcus Phoenix Phoenix's
son yeah
um Junior so maybe they can pull
something out of that I don't know I'm a
little more excited than I was two
months ago all right but he's gonna be
the best father-son relationship God of
War
oh God it's a new thing g-o-w or g-o-w
speaking of father-son relationships
sure why not the Last Guardian uh it has
a release date now I guess September
right yes it's just October October 23rd
is that what it is yeah like two days
ago okay so it's a little bit later near
actually uh what do we think about that
I mean it's such an unknown quantity I
feel like it's unknown but where does
past work kind of speaks for itself I
think when you come when you are trying
to figure out what to expect from this
game um like it's going to be very
atmospheric it's going to be very subtle
cues that communicate what most games
try to communicate through overt uh you
know dialogue or uh stuff you know I I
just I think that this game will be
special but whether or not it's going to
be amazing and worth the 10 11 years
we've waited for it right that I really
can't say it's really hard to know yeah
sorry I jumped the gun there that's
coming out October 25th so that's right
back to September time uh Final Fantasy
15 September 30th yeah there you go very
very worried about that it's everyone
I've talked to about this seems to be
like super worried the first two demos
they put out it was kind of encouraging
because it's like okay cool we're
getting a slice of this game we've been
waiting for and it's competent it's
doing new things and it's for the most
part succeeding at them but then they
showed that and I hate to just like take
one bad you know example right and call
the game out but the E3 demo was awful
there's no getting around that like not
even just the way that that the person
playing the demo performed it just
looked like a really poorly constructed
boss battle Yeah
and then the VR thing they showed and
then everything I've heard is played it
just sounds like it's a joke and I worry
that this game is sort of like trying to
do too much or maybe trying to do too
much and just relying on spectacle to
sort of uh be its main selling point
um because you know we we know how
combat kind of works we kind of know who
the characters are but there isn't a
great sense of how the game how it all
ties together and I think that is going
to be the bigger thing and if the
details they're in aren't good
it's it's probably going to be kind of
problematic but I hope it's great I
gotta love Final Fantasy I've been
waiting for this game for a long time
and Tabata is a nice guy who seems to
know what he's doing we just have to
wait and see yeah uh okay let's shift
from the world jrpgs to I guess the Big
Easy Mafia 3 October 7th uh y'all
looking forward to this I've been very
interested in what they're doing it
seems like a unique setting a unique
character
um what do you think Mike I really like
period pieces and games I remember like
LA Noire despite all its faults I'm
still like want to play that game just
for the kind of setting it created that
like The Saboteur yeah I also like to
have a tour okay I like that as well uh
I'd like their I liked Assassin's Creed
before it got pretty you know wrote
um but that's what I mainly attracted to
with Mafia 3 and it sounds like it's a
cool character the main one uh it sounds
like it's dealing with some pretty heavy
issues see how they actually execute on
those we'll see but yeah I'm excited for
that uh Battlefield one we've talked a
bit about it already today October 21st
any interest in here well I know you're
interested Mike yeah I'm super
interested and I'm someone who I don't
really care about Battlefield as a
series and doom is like the doom and
Titanfall the only first person shooters
I've actually really enjoyed uh for a
long time uh but watching these guys
play Battlefield one today like the
setting looks right the weapons the the
vehicles all that looks so good
I I am very excited to play it actually
all right let's talk about timefall as
well because that's our uh pretty
quickly after October 28th yeah
following week a campaign I know who
knew yeah well I guess it was what
everyone was asking for for the longest
time uh excited about it definitely
there you go
[Laughter]
uh me too I mean I like Mex it's it's a
fun uh shooting game otherwise and
there's a lot of great Mobility like
it's hard not to love that game the
first one especially it was like the
first game that started off that big
wave of yo let's make first person
shooters interesting again with movement
yeah we've kind of had a lot of it now
we've had riches in terms of that for
the past two years uh it'll be
interesting to see what they can do to
sort of I guess reaffirm their position
as the the head honchos with that stuff
yeah I played a couple matches at E3
it's really fun so the the Titans
themselves are like superheroes now
there's ion who is it's all like all
those attacks are laser attacks right
it's attacks uh Scorch Flames so it's
really cool like Vincent Paulo is saying
that robot wars yeah yeah they're saying
there's a big like Matilda coming out to
go back to Street Fighter they said
there's a big fighting game influence on
it you know like you start to learn I'm
sorry hear me out it's like Dark Souls
no I don't want to hear that all right
okay like
Vince oppana literally said the same
[Music]
to talk about this game this one's like
Sub-Zero
this guy's like noob sidebot
you're right Mike yeah I'm all right
it's really fun coming out excited
coming out October 28th I mean it's
really weird because it's wedged in
between the other two it's going to be
mental Battlefield 21st Titanfall 2 28th
November 4th Call of Duty infinite
Warfare looking forward to that at all
I kinda I love I like space I like Space
Battles space I always like personal
space personal space I do need some
personal space I freaked out a day the
other day oh yeah yeah that'll happen
yeah they may get made a game about that
it's called Space Invaders it's classic
wow
that was good that's good that's good I
like you have to credit my friend he
actually said that oh boo get out of
here friend joke he doesn't he doesn't
read or watch though who is it worth no
I'm back home okay you don't need to
know shout out Nico I know what up
Nico yeah is he was he the star of Grand
Theft Auto 4 no okay it's shame he's
Italian yeah all right Peter hi Call of
Duty infinite Warfare yeah I like Call
of Duty campaigns I like space
stick it on the box Infinity Ward I mean
I'm super like down on look at these
guys getting rolled over by a [__]
helicopter that's so dumb um I'm super
like not interested in the past couple
called it dirty games are they've been
fine they've just been known quantities
there's something about this I liked
what they showed at E3 because it was
them saying hey guess what combat has
fundamentally changed because we're
going to be using space in interesting
ways um and I like the jet pack and the
hook and all that stuff so I am I'm sort
of hoping this will be
um an interesting new take on the
formula they certainly seem to be trying
to do it and I think it's difficult for
them to change it up too much because
they risk alienating a lot of people who
are super into Call of Duty every single
year
so we'll have to see Dishonored 2 who
likes it yeah all right two hands off
that's coming at November 11th right
after Call of Duty there's a lot of
video games coming out
um yeah I mean this game has been a long
time coming it looks beautiful when we
saw D3 yeah
yeah the actual like moment-to-moment
gameplay between uh now there's two
characters of corvo and Emily yeah I
believe uh Emily being the one you like
rescued in the first game so it's pretty
badass to get the player but her she
also has a very different style to her
gameplay instead of like blinking into
the tendrils right that she's shooting
out like a grappling hook kind of thing
um Jackie estacado Into Darkness
tendrils yes uh yeah they also showed a
bunch of these new powers it looks like
it's going to be more of Dishonored one
which I'm not I'm not disappointed in uh
knowing like Arcane Studio well I mean
not knowing them I don't know them well
they have like two games I don't know
three games I don't know but a lot of a
lot of people who've made a lot of great
and oh yeah their roots go back to like
the System Shock days from like looking
glass Studios stuff and all that yes
good stuff I'm looking forward to how
like the experimentation is going to
play out with the different powers and
everything uh another game coming out
from a studio that we may or may not
know I don't know I'm running out of
Segways here uh four days after that the
Watchdogs dose uh what do we think of
Watch Dogs do I was very interested when
I first showed it off I was kind of like
cautiously optimistic
um talking to the guys at E3 I'm a
little bit less I was interested in them
really like tackling the whole East Bay
West Bay kind of thing yeah and then it
sounds like oh yeah some of our
designers lived there for like a year
yeah it's like wow like like I I it just
seems like if you're going to take an
African-American protagonist and throw
them into San Francisco's like crazy you
know white gentrification world you
really need to jump into that I mean
it's something like I live in Oakland
and it's like that's like the constant
like that's what people are talking
about yeah you know what I mean so it's
it's from talking to them it seems like
they are probably going to delicately
acknowledge and not jump too far into it
which I'm a little bit disappointed
about but apart from that I'm I'm very
interested in playing this game in a way
in terms of like just pure gameplay the
whole like hacking any car hacking a lot
of stuff I like the idea of doing that
the one thing well one of the many many
problems I have with the First Watch
Dogs was that the way you completed
levels was so unbelievably [__] roast
like it was like do this thing jump from
this camera to this camera and none of
it was particularly fun so I don't know
a little bit more player agency like go
a long way what do you think about it
Peter I mean like we're sort of I think
biased a little bit because it's set you
know a place I've lived for a decade
maybe it's not as important to to you
Mike I mean you hate San Francisco yeah
he called it San Francisco earlier just
stupid said his friend made that joke
I'm just gonna kick my ass after you
what is going on yeah what is this
animosity did I say something to you
today he just reviewed too many games
okay I'm excited for them to God takes
me so seriously yeah it is nothing about
it is yeah it's in your hometown or it's
in your like your backyard it's fun
right yeah it's like a fun thing
uh I look you see this laptop with like
a sticker on it that says hacker
that immediately raises alarms for me
because it's like the tone of this game
is probably gonna be [__] Peter it says
hacksor oh
[Music]
the tone of this game I I don't know my
hopes I don't have high hopes that it's
going to be able to uh accomplish it you
know their stated goal of
dealing with cultural issues in the Bay
Area which for someone who lives here
like these are things you see every day
it's not just like something you throw
you throw on because it's fashionable to
talk about like it affects real people
and so and it's the same thing with
Mafia right like how how are these games
going to handle these seemingly serious
issues yeah seemingly these serious
issues
um I don't know I don't know I feel like
that is going to be the bigger problem
for me than the gameplay when it comes
to watch dogs yeah it's going to be
interesting Mama hoping yeah I'm sort of
a little bit maybe not as optimistic of
either game doing it necessarily uh but
we'll have to wait and see uh that's uh
Watch Dogs 2 it's not the last game at
though there is something about South
Park games I like to launch them like
December 6th the fractured butthole yeah
looking forward to that love it can't
wait yeah you like buttholes Mike
I just played a stick of truth recently
for the first time
Decker yeah and it's it was incredibly
funny and uh I'm looking forward to more
South Park yeah that humor is always
welcome yay and that's all the games
that I have prepared on this this and I
forget anything I probably did did I
forget anything Mike uh deus ex man kind
of it I'm excited about totally because
I really liked Human Revolution but it
definitely had problems in its structure
and how you you know you're punished it
was like the same thing with the first
Dishonored you're kind of punished for
going a certain route after a while and
also civilization six I'm really excited
about right and how they are kind of
revamping how cities work and make you
think about the map differently as a big
civilization fan step five is still one
of my favorite games uh six has me
excited is it weird like I'm not someone
who plays a lot of strategy games but
when he was describing the changes to
sieve where it's like all the
complexities of a city aren't
encapsulated on just one part of the
grid now they're spread out to me that
sounds kind of like basic game Evolution
like after it took you six games to do
this it took you decades
yeah it's it's yeah that that's was my
takeaway but I played it for about an
hour and it seemed there's a lot of
smaller things that aren't things you
could just like say without going to a
feature list that have changed yeah
um it does make you think about the map
differently because resources figure
into different city districts in a way
that impacts the overall structure yeah
I completely see what you're saying
though because that was my initial uh
that was my initial kind of hesitance I
mean it sounds no I'm not saying like it
makes me pass uh not like interested in
the game I'm like I'm glad it's here but
it's also like all right it's fine if
you hate civilization
civilization Six coming uh pretty soon
October 21st
um just uh I guess the same day as
Battlefield one actually so you can get
here great you get your destruction of
civilizations on in many different ways
uh and Deus Ex mankind divided much
closer October 23rd so just a couple
days before Gears of War
[Music]
two months I had no idea right yeah yeah
so it hasn't I was lying I was deceitful
okay before I wrap this up was the one
game out of all those you're looking
forward to the most no man's Sky Gears
War Final Fantasy 15 Mafia three
Battlefield 1 Last Guardian Titanfall 2
Call of Duty infinite Warfare
Dishonored 2 Watchdog 2 and I guess
civilization six oh yeah Deus Ex
wait you go first uh Michael uh
civilization six okay Last Guardian
right
uh I'm gonna go no man's sky I don't
know it's been watching it close for a
while typical Irish sticking together
unbelievable nonsense all right let's uh
let's wrap this one off it's been a long
show thank you so much Michael my heart
for coming on
abusing you for an hour no it wasn't you
I wasn't not okay you Peter can you know
why don't we just cancel our date
tonight I have a feeling that if it's
just gonna be more of this I don't
really want to do it
around sounds good sorry about your uh
lost live streaming this horrible
breakup but thank you so much for going
on my pleasure
[Music]
uh crew as ever Richard Lee Eric hey
Mary Kish uh Jean-Luc seipy on the
Wheels of Steel this week thank you so
much sir uh we'll be back in a couple of
days we're back in a week with more
Lobby don't you know be back here with
more live streams as well on twitch.tv4
Gamespot gamespot.com hit that follow
button and if you're listening on your
podcast machine thank you so much I hope
you're enjoying us back after a little
bit of a Hiatus we'll be here until the
end of the year talking all about video
games so make sure you hit that
subscribe button if this is the first
time you've listened thank you so much
for watching we'll see you next week and
if we don't we'll see you on
gamespot.com adios
foreign
[Music]